[Music]
in the oceans deaths two titans wage
battle the sperm whale and the colossal
squid sperm whales use echolocation to
hunt these squid for food but even
against this gigantic animal squid can
put up an impressive fight scientists
know this because on the bodies of
washed up whales they frequently find
huge round suction scars emblazoned
there by large grasping tentacles
ranging in size from this Giants
impressive 14 meters to the 2.5
centimeters of the southern pygmy squid
these creatures fall into the group of
animals known as cephalopods
there are about 500 squid species
worldwide and they live in all the
world's oceans making them a reliable
food source for whales dolphins sharks
seabirds fish and even other squid
indeed squid themselves are fearsome
ocean predators but their most
extraordinary adaptations are those that
have evolved to help them form their
predators squid which can be found
mainly in estuary deep sea and open
water habitats often swim together in
shoals being out in the open without
anywhere to hide makes them vulnerable
so as a first line of defense they rely
on large well-developed eyes in the
colossal squid these are the size of
dinner plates the largest known eyes in
the animal kingdom when it's dark or the
water is murky however squid rely on a
secondary sensory system made from
thousands of tiny hair cells that are
only about 12 microns long and run along
their heads and arms each of these hair
cells is attached to axons in the
nervous system
swimming animals create awake so when
the hairs on the squids body detect this
motion they send a signal to the brain
which helps it determine the direction
of the waters flow
this way a squid can sense an oncoming
predator in even the dimmest waters
aware of the threat a squid can then
mask itself from a predator squid skin
contains thousands of tiny organs called
chromatophores each made of black brown
red or yellow pigments and ringed in
muscle reflecting cells beneath the
chromatophores mirror the squids
surroundings enabling it to blend in so
when the muscles contract the color of
the pigment is exposed whereas when the
muscles relaxed
the colors are hidden each of these
chromatophores is under the individual
control of the squids nervous system so
while some expand others remain
contracted that enables counter shading
where the underside of the squid is
lighter than the top to eliminate a
silhouette that a predator might spy
from below some predators however like
the whales and dolphins get around this
ruse by using sound waves to detect a
squids camouflaged form not to be
outfoxed the squid still has two more
tricks up its sleeve the first involves
ink produced inside its mantle squid ink
is made mostly of mucus and melanin
which produces its dark coloring when
squid eject the ink they either use it
to make a large smoke screen that
completely blocks the Predators view or
a blob that roughly mimics the size and
shape of the squid this creates a
phantom form called a pseudo morph that
tricks the predator into thinking it's
the real squid as a final touch
squid rely on jet propulsion to rapidly
shoot away from their hunters reaching
speeds of up to 25 miles per hour and
moving meters away in mere seconds this
makes them Earth's fastest invertebrates
some squid species have also developed
unique adaptive behaviors the deep-sea
vampire squid when startled uses its
webbed arms
to make a cape it hides behind the tiny
bobtail on the other hand tosses sand
over its body as it burrows away from
prying eyes the Pacific flying squid
uses jet propulsion for another purpose
to launch itself right out of the water
squids inventive adaptations have
allowed them to proliferate for over 500
million years even now we're still
uncovering new species and as we do were
bound to discover even more about how
these stealthy cephalopods have mastered
survival in the deep and unforgiving sea
descend into the deepest reaches of the
ocean with this playlist
[Music]